never have I ever fallen asleep during a
game pictures over your life
hi I'm Tony Johnson hello I'm Dustin
mate hey I'm Matt baby and today we're
playing never have I ever
it's gonna be who's gonna be great and
learning about these guys and one day
yeah done it not done
never ever worn dirty underwear or socks
because of a superstition oh well I mean
lived out of a suitcase since April 30th
so I got the same stuff but yeah if you
hit a home run or something like that
you got to go with the same underwear
that day might be a little it sounds a
little nasty but I mean I'm when we come
to the field we're clean and showered
and then we leave we're cleaned and
showered so I mean I wear the same one
but I always wash them so never have I
ever received unsolicited hitting tips
from a significant other no no about a
significant other but my grandma used to
tell me see the ball hit the ball
parents definitely said quite a few
things about that my wife gets really
mad at me if I take a first pitch
fastball and it's a strike so she used
to get onto me a lot about it not so
much anymore never have ever gotten lost
in and around a stadium absolutely the
first time I came here this offseason no
clear I was gone I got lucky a coach
pulled out for the in his car he's like
followed me I know we're gonna like
thank you
I actually just got lost in Atlanta yeah
I was walking around down downstairs and
just kept walking past the clubhouse and
I had to ask people like hey where's the
club I'll search right there I never
ever ever binge watched a whole Netflix
series in a single day for sure
strangers things the sinner definitely
stranger things was was by on the top of
the list on that one never have I ever
wanted to sway sports I think we've just
probably all been playing baseball ever
since we know anything so why not true
love that's what we that's what we chose
to do from a young age never have I ever
forgotten a teammates name there's
definitely been a lot of teammates over
the
it's just like uh I don't remember you
so we're just gonna say hello I feel
like a lot of times I'll remember
someone's last name and not their first
name or vice versa never have I ever
fallen asleep during a game the best
life bullpen life back in college I mean
yeah summer ball put the shades on
exactly the same I was just in high
school when I did it so she didn't have
any other reason I was not playing so
why not never I've ever pranked a
teammate I've wanted to prank him a
couple times but I don't want to mess up
his start yeah we might have some
fighting issues Oh literally fighting if
I touch a glove in Atlanta somebody like
taped a snake to the bottom of the code
that's a kid oh ha I got it like a whiz
they got me he got me with that yeah
yeah I'm like you pull the lid up from
the cooler and a snake came popping out
of it kind of looked it looked pretty
real yeah how does he get one never have
I ever eaten a Dodger dog during a game
I mean not like while I was playing I've
never had a Dodger dog I'm probably
gonna need to try one it's good it's
good yeah there's ever a little
neighborhood worth eating another one
yeah I'd eat another one never have I
ever hung out with an opponent before or
after a game I feel like during the game
like you can be like enemies whatever
like pulling against this guy but after
the game you're still friends at the end
of the day yeah
never have I ever forgot my spot in the
lineup there's been times I ran in from
defense and I'm like oh crap where am i
hitting oh definitely happen a few times
growing up never have I ever used my
celebrity status to get into a booked
restaurant I don't really think any of
us has been too long to experience that
yeah we're all rookies so we're uh maybe
in a few years but not not yet never
have I ever wore someone else's uniform
I mean I've pitched in his pants before
they're pretty long but yeah how did
that work never have I ever cried while
watching at Disney MIDI
rankings Disney right that was a good
movie just just watch The Lion King last
week I know a lot of people that cried
during lion
let me do the same thing never have I
ever got caught singing in the car /
shower those are the only two places I
sing so I've definitely gotten caught
yeah I don't know if cuts the right word
just kind of singing along in the car
not really whatever I pulled up beside
in your leg I mean they might have but I
probably didn't make out yeah I was not
experienced I also follow a playlist
songs to sing to in the shower so I was
a pretty good one chuck it out on
Spotify never have I ever stolen a
teammate's piece of equipment
I usually I'm a big big ask before I
take something kind of person so I
usually just take it this don't like if
you borrow and then you don't give it
back is that stolen yeah belly let me
use his bat in the cage the other day
and it's just sitting him about that oh
yeah you got to take that one yeah I
keep that one for you got to ask him to
sign it yeah keep that close to heart
and having it back yet oh that's fine I
like these guys are fun no I'm pretty
boy and it's great to learn you know
sometimes stuff and don't let baby
borrow anything yeah he's not gonna get
about it so gotta be careful with this a
bleeding
[Music]